So listen, this, this next story gives me
no pleasure to tell you this, but I do a political
show and when I have a personal experience
that's relevant to the 2020 democratic primary,
that is an important topic on this program.
I have to tell you about it.
It would be really weird for me not to talk
about this.
Now, as many of you know, I'm voting for Bernie
Sanders in the Massachusetts primary on March
3rd, I would vote for any of the democratic
candidates over Donald Trump and I will support
the eventual nominee.
Good.
Uh, yeah.
Okay.
So, so far I've been canvassed by two campaigns
here in Massachusetts.
Two weeks ago a Bloomberg canvasser volunteer
came to my door and talk to me about Michael
Bloomberg.
Um, and this week, the Bernie Sanders campaign,
it came to my door to Bernie Sanders.
They were volunteers.
This was not paid.
Staff came to my door.
Uh, I didn't immediately tell them who I was
voting for and they very quickly, instead
of talking up Bernie about his policies, they
immediately started attacking Elizabeth Warren
to my face.
And I think this is a terrible strategy.
If I were Bernie Sanders, I wouldn't want
my canvassers doing this.
And by the way, I'm sure Bernie does it.
I mean clearly these were folks who were not
following, you know, patent max a told, hold
us on the bonus show last week that they went
up to New Hampshire to canvas for Bernie ahead
of the New Hampshire primary and they had
an app and the app outlines how to handle
different types of objections a and nowhere
in there.
Was there anything about attacking other candidates?
So to be very clear, these were obviously
not individuals acting on the direction from
the Bernie Sanders campaign, but it should
be made super clear I think to everybody who
is volunteering to canvas for Bernie or whoever
do not bad mouth other candidates don't do
it because it makes you look bad and also
don't do it because if the primary thing in
the end is to remove Donald Trump, we don't
want to campaign for our candidate in a way
that could potentially hurt the eventual nominee
in the future if it is to be someone else
and they they the people who came to my door,
to the Bernie supporters, the canvassers were
saying things like, we support Bernie because
Elizabeth Warren doesn't really care about
working people like Bernie does.
They said that on healthcare.
Elizabeth Warren doesn't even care about giving
everyone health care right away and I think
the spontaneous attacks on Warren are bad.
Maybe here in Massachusetts we're seeing some
of it because the last poll we have is from
October, but at the time Warren was the presumptive
front runner here.
Although we haven't had a poll in months,
and I don't know who's actually winning.
Uh, and I don't even think that using the
word, I don't think Warren wants to give everyone
healthcare.
I don't even think that's the right language
in my mind.
I would be talking about Bernie wants to ensure
everybody receives the healthcare they need,
which to me sounds better than using this
language of giving everyone healthcare.
So again, these were volunteer canvassers.
Um, they are, you know, based on what Pat
told us, they get a 30 minute training of
some kind before going out there and doing
their thing.
Um, clearly these were folks who I give them
the benefit of the doubt.
I assume they have the best intentions.
They're campaigning for the person they think
is best for the country, and they're doing
it vigorously and they are trying to do it
in the way that they believe would be most
persuasive but persuasive.
But the point is, if Bernie is the nominee,
we don't gain anything.
By going around and attacking Elizabeth Warren
to people you've just met, who you haven't
even revealed yet how they plan to vote.
Had I been a Warren support supporter, am
I going to be convinced to vote Bernie because
two canvassers showed up at my house and trashed
the person that may be I'm considering supporting.
I don't think so.
I'm not going to say, you know, I didn't think
about that about it that way.
Warren doesn't care about working people.
I'm going to switch my vote to Bernie.
I'm not blaming Bernie.
These aren't paid campaign staff.
These were volunteers, but it's not good in
general.
You don't want to do canvassing where you
show up and attack other candidates, either
point out objective policy, policy, things
that you believe another candidate has done
wrong.
Say Elizabeth Warren signed this and Bernie
was against it.
Oh, okay.
Well that, that's information that's useful.
But in reality, just talk about why the person
you support is the best person and why I should
vote for them.
And there's, you know, a lot of really bogus,
uh, Bernie bro was mean on Twitter stuff floating
around the internet.
That's not what this is.
That is actually a coordinated campaign to
go after Bernie supporters as a proxy to attacking
Bernie.
I'm talking merely about campaign strategy
and I think that attacking other candidates
at people's doors is bad strategy.
It's likely that these individuals, uh, were,
were a little, um, overexuberant and they
went in a direction that didn't make sense.
And in fact, Pat said a lot of what he was
doing when he canvassed for Bernie in New
Hampshire was ascertaining if the person planned
to vote for Bernie Sanders and, uh, saying,
you know, consider Bernie in a more friendly
way.
Let me know what you think of this.
Let me know if anybody has canvas you and
whether you experienced something similar,
different from Bernie canvassers or other
canvassers.
Again, I've only been approached by Bloomberg
supporters, Bloomberg campaign people, and
Bernie campaign people.
At this point in time